ah
qu'est ce que vous faites là toutes les
deux halloween on appelle tour du
quartier vous êtes tout seul il ya un
mec celle où avec un masque blanc qui
arrêtent pas
d'essayer de jouer à cache cache avec
nous il craint où vous l'avez vu ce
titre
ouais
c'est votre fait
ouvrez la porte allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sow
à tuer michael
ma grand mère a mis feu
personne ne vous a rien dit
sa venue michael myers est toujours en
vie
aucun homme n'aurait pu survivre à cet
incendie
il y à 40 ans le croquemitaine venu pour
nous tuer nous sommes les rescapés de
michael meier sais quoi mais on la
france maman c'est à nous de le tuer on
va le traquer et mettre fin à tout ça
il ne s'arrêtera pas de tuer tant qu'on
me laissera faire
au regard doux michael n'a frappé ou
peut être assimilée
qui mène droit sa maison d'enfance
il ya quelques qui rentrait chez nous
il vient me chercher et c'est moi qui
vais le trouver
si tu veux tu as quelqu'un pape et hagen
je veux lui retirer son masque et voir
dans ses yeux la vie qui sait